that was this is was this it that was it
that we saw
that's chris right there a lot of
snapping involved chris matthews
is live in studio and he's dancing his
way into the playoffs the golden knights
heading into the postseason here's chris
live dancing optional
well hey we'll do it all day yeah there
are some complete
things going on here now with a salary
cap no restrictions now here in the
postseason so
the knights will have a full roster when
they begin playoffs either sunday or
monday
now if the kings beat the avalanche
tonight vegas opens on monday against st
louis if colorado beats la as expected
well the knights will open sunday
against minnesota
vegas will go into the postseason with
marc-andre fleury and robin leonard
the two goalies won the jennings trophy
for the best goalie tandem in the league
now that's a first for flower obviously
the players in front did a great job you
know blocking a lot of shots up to the
south and
robin had a great season too and also
it's an honor to be able to get that
trophy for me hands down
the best goalie tandem in the league um
i i like to think that trophy and i'm
sure they would say this is a
is also a team defense trophy and i
think they got
uh some good help from our commitment to
defending
interesting to see what coach peter
deboer decides with his goaltenders now
that the postseason is here he was going
back and forth and by the way
the cheapest tickets to t-mobile for
game one on either sunday or monday
is 152 dollars now there aren't many
available i'm kind of wondering
with the new cdc announcements today on
mass vaccines and social distancing
if southern nevada health officials will
allow more fans inside the fortress
prior to june 1st brian that's a great
question chris could that i mean perfect
timing in a way
if they do allow some more in it's also
going to open up more tickets to
knights fans who have been shut out with
the limited seating yeah it's going to
be interesting to see what happens here
because coming out of the west it's
going to be colorado probably
or the vegas gold knights two of the
best teams in the nhl so really
whoever wins the west will have the
number one seed throughout the nhl
postseason playoffs we got a fun couple
of weeks ahead of us